all right what's the matter partner it's
official old buddy hasn't been a man
congratulations to you this is massive
it's so exciting all right so once upon
a time in 1990 we had our first ET
interview with you and I want you to
hear what you had to say
[Music]
right storytellers
Oh a little guy where's he gone I wanted
to ask you now you're the big people on
set and other actors are coming to set
excited to work with you and nervous to
be around Leonardo DiCaprio do you feel
that do you help mentor them you have an
amazing co-star in this movie I sure do
look I mean this is a rare sort of
occurrence
Hollywood's changing in a lot of ways
this is kind of an art film that's a
throwback to a different type of
filmmaking and to sit back and look at
that little guy and say that I'm able to
still do this and be a part of a film
like this it's pretty humbling it's I
feel lucky is what I feel I feel lucky
to be to been an actor that's been able
to work for this long you and Brad your
chemistry in this movie is next-level
it's so special how did you guys just
make that magic actually you know it
really came naturally I think that we're
both live in Los Angeles this is about
the changing of the culture in the late
60s and basically you know we understand
these dynamics of these professional
relationships that also turn into
families my stunt double I'm an
out-of-work kind of actor it's
struggling to make the transition into
the in the upcoming 70s and I'm sort of
a remnant of the past but Brad and I as
soon as we step into these shoes Quinton
gave us this amazing backstory of our
characters and what we've been through
and it was one of the more easy sort of
natural fits that I think I've ever
experienced because we kind of knew who
these guys were
[Music]